[Musique]
le collège emilien dans de villiers a
fêté en 2018 ses 20 ans 20 ans
d'histoire pour ce collège qui a ouvert
ses portes seulement sept ans après la
fermeture définitive de l'usiné de grand
bois
retour sur l'histoire du collège et de
son quartier il y a vingt ans le collège
était très différent ce qui a changé
c'est qu'on est parti de deux niveaux 6e
5e petite équipe très restreinte dizaine
de profs et maintenant on est à 7 cents
à peu près 700 élèves 50 profs les
bâtiments aussi ont beaucoup changé
la plus de végétation il ya des
bâtiments plus quand je suis arrivé ici
à presque 20 ans 19 ans en fait il n'y
avait pas d'installations sportives
couvertes et je suis arrivé donc dans un
établissement où il y avait un terrain
sportif en plein plein soleil c'était
extrêmement difficile pour les élèves
c'était difficile pour nous et 7 8 ans
après il ya eu la construction d'un
gymnase
j'ai naze richardson en face qui nous a
vraiment changé les conditions de
travail les élèves aussi ont beaucoup
changé génération zapping génération
virtuelle génération qui a besoin de
voir les choses allaient très rapidement
[Musique]
judith notre invité à la fête du collège
rentrée en sixième au moment de
l'ouverture de l'établissement ya ma
fille qui est au collège et qui a eu la
même professeur que moi d'histoire-géo
adam carroll patricia madame carreaux
patrice et à midi de la tutoyer
maintenant donc ça fait bizarre j'avais
toujours eu ce vouvoiement kit est
toujours présent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est
le collège et milliards dans deux villes
et doit son nom au célèbre directeur de
la sucrerie de grand bois
cette usine s'est arrêtée définitivement
de fonctionner en 1991 autour de
celle-ci s'est créé un quartier qui a
évolué au cours du temps
nous sommes ici à l' usine de grand bois
qui a été fondée par la famille shopi en
les ouvriers qui travaillaient venaient
essentiellement d'un monsieur emilien
dans de vignes et en a été le directeur
jusqu'à sa mort en 2002 lusine est
classé monument historique et
aujourd'hui on peut y trouver une crèche
des logements sociaux des commerces et
bientôt une médiathèque
en tant que parents d'élèves mais aussi
guide du patrimoine
monsieur d'emile nous parle de
l'histoire de son quartier bon dans un
ciel mais la famille shopi va régner sur
ce domaine et à partir des années 1950
entendrez mais la famille adam de
villiers va être le propriétaire et le
directeur de ses terres jusqu'à 1900
emilien dans de villiers était un
passionné de courses hippiques
mais également de mécanique et
d'aviation c'était une personne
exigeante dans le travail mais apprécié
de tous ses employés pour ses qualités
humaines
on va avoir trois usines lusine de
kaffrine où on est lusine de grand-bois
centre qui a vécu jusqu'en 1991
l usine de lens qui était aussi al
attiyah de grand bois dans les années
1900 en voiture vers 1700 les
propriétaires utilisaient des esclaves
pour cultiver la canne et produire le
sucre jusqu'à l'abolition en 1848 à
proximité de l'usiné de grand bois se
trouvent les calbanons les logements des
esclaves puis des engagés indiens
on va avant quatre différentes
contingent donc le l'indien le taf le
malgache et le rodriguais par la suite à
l'abolition de l'esclavagé en 1848 il
faudra remplacer c'est la main devant
par des gens engagés maintenant un mets
qui vient
viendront du débat mme pays qu'on a
depuis le début de cette histoire en
1828 quoi madame peering la dernière
habitante des calbanons nous raconte
cette époque j'avais 8 ans et demi
niveaux comme ça et j'ai eu et j'ai vécu
là j'ai grandi là fut mariée lavent la
au cabanon
j'habitais si vous avez visité le
cabanon j'habitais dans la première
pièce est le cas ballon c'était un
endroit où les gens venaient et repartez
as beaucoup moins à passer la douane
depuis les graves âge jusqu'à la
fermeture de l'usiné n'y avait pas de
chambres partenaires et pas toi mais
paris n'y a cédé à l'e.coli année à
l'école mais pas beaucoup aller à
l'école très peu madame perrine était
également au service de la famille adam
de villiers en tant qu'employé de miss
monde en 2010 et le ps cet été le grand
homme bon et mes gentils mais gentil
mais s'occuper frévent de son propre
cuisine c'est que ça compte et polluent
on discutait pas avec les patrons ou
dans notre place nous commander pour
seattle j'ai besoin de quelque chose
comme ça comme les ondes comme les
employés de la maison de adam de
villiers et côté de la cuisine à côté
d'une usine et y'avait paddock
à côté il y avait des chevaux que le
fils adam l'olivier faisait 2d ques
degrés c'était comme une fête impasse
n'avait pas beaucoup d'activités il y
avait deux cuisiniers avaient des
jardiniers et ce mode de vie passé fait
aujourd'hui partie de notre identité
dans notre collège nous avons voulu la
transmettre en célébrant la fête du 20
décembre
l'idée c'est de faire partager aux
élèves l'histoire
notre île c'est vrai qu'on est parti du
constat qui connaissent très peu leur
histoire on peut le but c'était
d'organiser un certain nombre
d'activités ludiques afin de partager ça
on met en place plusieurs ateliers un
atelier maloya avec démonstrations ainsi
qu'une initiation aux instruments de
musique atelier jardin longtemps l
atonie jeu longtemps on a fait aussi des
comptes à l'idée c'était de dans la
transmission d'en faire replonger un
petit peu les élèves dans les légendes
du passé
le but c'était de faire un bond dans le
temps que les élèves puissent se rendre
compte du mode de vie de leurs aînés
tout en gardant une approche positive
des choses qu est ce que la conteuse
temps raconté j ai raconté qu'avant
c'était difficile de vivre qu'on était
esclave
on ne pouvait pas échapper facilement et
c'est un beau message c'est un bon
moment fins et c'est une fois quand on
va à d'activision a insulté dans ce cas
là c'est émouvant où se rattache
vraiment aubin à nos racines je sais pas
trop comment expliquer mais voilà déjà
il n'y a pas les mêmes conditions
qu'aujourd'hui ça c'est sûr mais déjà
bas on n'avait pas la liberté donc dias
est assez simple n'avait pas la liberté
liberté d'expression que ça bah il n'y
avait pas toutes les libertés qu'on a
aujourd'hui
il n'avait pas tout ça moi cette musique
faire passer c'est faire comprendre mode
normal que le temps esclavage l'été
c'était
attendez difficile fait partie de
l'histoire et apprennent à plein
d'histoires sur bandes marron esclaves
marrons
donc c'est ça aujourd'hui mais sait y
faire passer ces histoires-là effet à
comprendre c'est que vraiment c'était un
les pages et panaf est allé aussi loin
que ça et c'est avec la mort clinique
l'histoire nous prend conscience de ce
que l'école est un lieu de transmission
de valeurs mais aussi de notre
patrimoine culturel
à l'heure des avancées technologiques en
tout genre il est bon de se rappeler
d'où l'on vient
j'ai dit aux jeunes là c'est de bien
bosser à l'école c'est de bien
travailler comme ça c'est pas leur
viendrait pas comme moi avec une brosse
copeaux soupçonne qu'ils passent à
séduire
[Musique]